can we come in ten minutes are you there
we need to run fast it's a very hot day
hi this is Francesca speaking the
truffle lady can you tell him that we
are coming in ten minutes with the
truffles this truffle came in yesterday
night and our restaurant knows that as
soon as they arrived they want them we
have a very tight schedule because the
restaurants warm the delivery before the
service so today we have several
appointments we need to move very fast
okay first step is the first season
this ever many different ways we serve
him on egg we said when the hospitai
said that a risotto you see the smell
let's do smell it oh I'm ready for some
oyster now the perfume is unbelievable
to fill the whole kitchen thank you bye
bye
I ran the best part of being a truffle
rep is that did you get to go for the
main dining room because we want the
people to see them Wow everybody else
into the back door we got almost the
pounds worth of black truffles today
which will last us through the weekend
probably thank you this morning this
morning Betsy alpha big rat okay says
that the price are the same monster for
next week and also the weather forecast
good they just walked in the front door
one day and just introduce themselves
showed me what they have and we kind of
just went from there
thank you hello
she only brings really good stuff look
cut those in the kitchen the smaller
ones and the bigger ones are kind of
like the show pieces of course we carry
a bit value but it's not a problem to
stroll around because something that as
a value but only if you have a company
that can sell
it's a never-ending job